Number five,
do not let your children do anything
that makes you dislike them.
This is sorta been a through line to at
least the beginning part of our council.
Well,
the first thing is it's the monster
thing,
like the beauty and beast thing.
You are not a good guy and you will take
revenge on your children if they
misbehave.
You Think,
oh no,
I liked my children.
It's like other people might not like
them.
Maybe they don't behave very well,
you know,
and you think you liked them because
you're a saint,
but you're not and you will take revenge
on those children if they do things that
make you dislike them.
So you're in the grocery store and
you've got a four year old and four year
olds,
pretty smart checking you out all the
time and like poking you and prodding
you and seeing what's there because
that's what little kids do.
They're not that verbal.
So they are,
they're,
they're like,
they,
they have.
You could compare their behavior in some
ways to pack animals like dogs,
which is why they like dogs and get
along with dogs.
They understand each other,
you know,
and so they're testing out and so they
have a temper tantrum in the store and
you don't know what to do about it.
What you do,
your kid has a temper tantrum in the
store.
You pick up the child,
you go outside with them,
you stand them up somewhere and just let
them have it.
Let them have the temper tantrum.
It's like they don't get sick of it.
Soon enough,
go somewhere boring and dull.
Say,
well,
have outer man.
Then the kids done.
You say,
we're going to stand right here until
you decide that you're going to behave.
The child knows what that means is like,
you're going to behave or we're just
gonna.
Stand here.
It's like,
fine,
okay.
You don't do that.
The child has a temper tantrum.
The third one,
you know you're embarrassed.
You're turning red.
Everyone's sweating.
Everyone's looking at you like you're a
horrible parent.
It's like really unpleasant thing.
Oh,
I love my child.
I liked my child.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
That's a lie.
You go home,
the kids forgotten all about it.
You know,
they go in their room,
they make a little drawing,
they're all thrilled that they come out
and show it to you and maybe they did a
really good job.
You know,
maybe there are even a little guilty
about having the Damn Tantrum,
but you,
man,
you're not happy and you think,
yeah,
that's nice and you go back to whatever
useless thing you're doing and you think
I got that little bastard and you think,
no,
I wouldn't think that.
It's like you're wrong.
You're wrong.
Not only would you think that you would
act it out,
and if you don't think that that's true,
then you don't know yourself very well
and so you got to think.
Now a little kid is little and powerless
while not as powerless as you might
think,
but fundamentally you got the upper hand
and you've got the proclivity for
tyranny deeply rooted in you and so you
better be real careful around that
child.
I,
I used to tell my kids,
you know,
when I was not in a good mood,
he say like it would be better if you
were in your room and they didn't mind.
They knew what it meant,
you know,
they were very young.
They could understand that.
It's like you're a fine kid,
you know,
pat,
Pat,
I'm not in a good mood.
Things are likely to be unpleasant.
Why don't you just go play in your room
for a while.
It's like way they went,
they knew how to play in their room,
you know,
because I didn't want them being around
me.
I wasn't being going to be a good guy.
And so in Kim's faith,
they know they can handle that man,
they can't handle lies,
they can handle that sort of truth,
no problem.
And so like I,
both my wife and I,
we very careful.
It's like when we're starting to not be
happy with the kids,
with one kid or the other,
it was time to have a chat and figure
out what it was that had gone off the
rails and how we were going to fix it.
So that we were like thrilled to have
that kid around.
And that's the thing about kids is you
can be thrilled to have them around.
Not always,
you're tired,
you're hung over like you've had a bad
day.
The kids cranky.
Like I'm not saying this is utopia.
It's not.
That's not the point.
The point is though,
you,
you can manage your relationship with
your kids and you can have an honest
relationship with them and then it will
be the best relationship with anybody
you've ever had in your life.